the 1990s brought us some incredible tv
with many shows still enjoyed today
audiences have developed emotional bonds
to these shows
and even the funniest 90 sitcoms had
their emotional scenes
here's a look back at the saddest
moments from popular 90s tv shows
ross and rachel's off and on
relationship captivated audiences
throughout friend's lengthy run
officially getting together in the
episode the one with the prom video
ross and rachel dated seriously for a
year until ross's jealousy over rachel's
new job and co-worker
led to their infamous break then when
ross assumed their break
really meant broken up he slept with
another woman breaking rachel's heart
and in the episode the one with the
morning after they
ended one of the most famous will they
won't they storylines on modern
television when rachel was unable to
forgive ross
rachel tearfully tells ross she believed
he would never hurt her
meanwhile ross has to face the fact he's
permanently altered
any relationship they could have
romantic or otherwise
and it's not only heartbreaking for them
but for their other friends
eavesdropping on the conversation from
another room
after watching two of their best friends
find happiness together
they now have to see it all fall apart
viewers rooting for ross and rachel
arguably find it the saddest moment of
their relationship
while viewers rooting against them may
find it just as sad when they learn it's
not actually the end
ross and rachel eventually ended up
together though many friends fans
now think they were really a terrible
match but whether you were in favor of
their relationship or not
the breakup episode is sad to watch
despite only airing for one season
freaks and geeks is even more
popular now than when it was actually on
the air and fans mourn its early
cancellation
the show's humor is still sharply funny
and some of its most memorable moments
were the more emotional ones
one standout example is in the episode
kim kelly is my friend
after butting heads with lindsay kim
decides to try to get along
and invites her to dinner with her
family lindsay is reluctant but
ultimately agrees during the dinner
scene kim's parents continually put her
down
making it clear to lindsay where kim
gets her mean tendencies
when kim insists a teacher was behaving
inappropriately toward her
her mother disregards her and the
conversation turns to a shouting match
kim's mother tells her that all she does
is [ __ ] around and threatens to take
kim's car away
it ends with kim and lindsay rushing
away in the car as kim's mother shouts
at her to never come back
the scene is necessary to the series
plot lines bringing much-needed
development to kim's character
and putting her previous mistreatment of
lindsay into perspective
but despite the clarity it brings to kim
and how lindsay sees her
it hurts to watch even people who
haven't seen the fresh prince of bel-air
probably know what it's about from its
wildly popular theme song in which will
smith narrates how he ends up living
with his aunt and uncle
in such a rich neighborhood what you
might not know is that the character of
will was abandoned as a child by his
father
and raised by his mother alone will's
father lou
returns unexpectedly in the episode
papa's got a brand new excuse
he spends time with will asking his
forgiveness and invites will on a summer
road trip
happy to have his father back and
convinced he has changed
will is upset by how skeptical his uncle
phil is about lou's sudden reappearance
will and phil argue and tensions are
high but
at the end of the episode lou leaves
again trying to make it out before will
sees him
sadly will arrives just in time
suitcases in hand
to see his dad take off yet again
afterward
will tries to brush it off saying he's
made it this far without his father
and can continue just fine the same way
but then
will eventually breaks down with the
heartbreaking final line of the episode
how come you don't want me man
boy meets world ran for seven seasons as
viewers watched corey and his friends go
from middle school kids to full-fledged
young adults in the series finale
the series beloved couple cory and
tapanga leave their hometown of
philadelphia for new york city
where topanga has landed a law
internship corey is initially freaked
out by the move
but eventually comes around to it the
really sad and memorable moment comes
when the group must say goodbye to their
longtime teacher mr feeney
the kids had mr feeny as their teacher
for their entire adolescence
as he moved with them between grades as
a neighbor to corey's family
he naturally developed a close bond with
corey and his friends
often providing advice and guidance and
despite insisting he thought of them
strictly as students
mr feeney clearly cared about each and
every one of them
in the final scene of the series each of
his former students
thanks mr feeney personally sean thanks
him for never giving up on it
eric says he taught him how to be a good
person tapanga tells him he was like a
father to her
and corey says he'll always be with them
dismissed
[Music]
twin peaks wasn't exactly an uplifting
series
the mystery drama followed an fbi
investigation into the murder of local
high school prom queen laura palmer
and inevitably was full of somber
moments
one of the most memorable comes just 12
minutes into the first episode
as laura's parents learn of her death
sarah palmer
laura's mother calls her husband leland
to tell him she doesn't know where laura
is
as leland tries to calm her down sheriff
truman comes to tell him the devastating
news
even before truman can say anything
leland begins to put it together
and so does sarah as leland asks if it's
about lara
truman responds i'm afraid it is leland
drops the phone
and sarah's muffled screams can be heard
through it i don't understand
twin peaks has plenty of crazy and
intense moments
but this one rooted in pure human grief
is easily one of the saddest
and the odd detail of leland and sarah
realizing their daughter is dead before
being told about it
helps set the dreamlike and bizarre tone
of the rest of the series
despite being a feel-good family comedy
the basic premise of full house is
really pretty sad after his wife's death
danny tanner asks his brother-in-law
and a close friend to move in to help
him raise his three daughters
over its eight season run the show had
many entertaining
and hilarious moments and remains a
generational touchstone for many
growing up without a mother the bonds
dany's daughters form with their uncles
jesse and joey
are some of the strongest and most
affecting of the series
and when jesse gets ready to move out of
the house after getting married
of course the girls are emotional about
it michelle the youngest
has the hardest time accepting it and
the scene where jessie says goodbye to
her
is one of the saddest of the show it's
hard enough when michelle thinks they're
all moving to jessie's new home and
packs up all of her things
it's even more emotional as the exchange
goodbye gets
with michelle giving jessie her stuffed
pig and jessie giving her his framed
pink bunny
and then exchange their actual goodbyes
but hardest of all is the moment where
michelle is left sadly on her bed when
jesse leaves
even though her uncle jesse will be
around the house all the time
michelle's heartbreak in that moment
makes the distance as real to the viewer
as it is to her
beverly hills 90210 was one of the most
popular shows of the 90s
the ensemble teen drama followed a group
of friends from high school into early
adulthood
in the wealthy city of beverly hills
california although frequently campy
the show dealt with plenty of serious
topics from dave rape to alcoholism
and more it had plenty of emotional and
sensitive moments throughout its run
and one of the saddest had to be the
death of tony shortly after she and
dylan were married
long before his relationship with tony
had developed dylan had planned revenge
against tony's father for his own
father's death
and after he married her tony's father
hired an assassin to kill dylan in
retaliation
but tony was tragically mistaken for
dylan instead
after hearing of impending trouble dylan
found tony dead in her car
shot multiple times by the hitman
dylan's desperate screams as he held
tony's body
were agonizing living single followed
six friends through their personal
and professional lives in brooklyn their
antics producing countless hysterical
moments
but some of the show's most
unforgettable moments were its more
serious ones
in the third season khadijah the
ambitious and hardworking editor of the
fictional magazine flavor
takes a second job as a security guard
at a retirement home to pay for
improvements at the magazine when it's
threatened by a rival publication
also stressed by her ex-fiance seeing
somebody new
khadijah begins losing sleep and
behaving erratically
on her mother's advice she reluctantly
sees a psychiatrist
and finally faces her growing depression
with khadijah acting restless and
fidgety during their session
her psychiatrist tells her she sees
signs of anxiety and possible bipolar
depression in her
happiest person
as she takes her first step toward
facing the pressure she's put herself
under
and its effects on her mental health
khadija tries to downplay what she's
going through
it's a hard first step to watch but when
she decides to continue therapy at the
end of the episode
it's as much a sigh of relief for the
audience as it is for khadijah
the x-files followed fbi special agents
fox mulder
and dana scully as they worked on
unsolved cases involving paranormal
activities
mulder was a believer in the paranormal
while scully a medical doctor
sought rational explanations for their
findings the x-files had its fair share
of deaths
but one of the saddest and most shocking
was easily the murder of scully's sister
melissa
while the scully sisters had their
differences dana remained a skeptic
while melissa was a firm believer in the
paranormal the two sisters
deeply cared about one another this
sharpened the tragedy when melissa was
killed in the first episode of the
series third season
especially as dana was indirectly a
reason for her sister melissa's death
tragically melissa entered her sister
dana's apartment while she was out
and was mistaken for her by two
assassins waiting there
and though scully eventually caught the
man who did it she never quite found
peace
family matters chronicled the lives of
the winslows a black family living in
chicago
at the start of the show married couple
harriet and carl winslow
invite harriet's recently widowed sister
rachel and her child to come stay with
them and their children
like other family sitcoms family matters
offered warmth and emotion
along with comedy and some of it came in
the form of sad and serious topics
as in the episode good cop bad cop in it
the winslow's oldest child eddie is
pulled over for a failed turn signal
his interaction with the cops soon turns
ugly as they make eddie lie
down and cuff him dad the only reason
they pulled me over
is because i was a black guy in a white
neighborhood
later carl confronts the cops who pulled
eddie over making for a memorable and
affecting scene that still
rings true today the older of the two
cops claims eddie fit the profile of a
carjacking suspect
but carl insists this isn't true he
shoots down
every excuse arguing the altercation
happened merely because eddie is a black
man
as the older cop storms out carl asks
the younger one why he likes being a cop
the officer responds that he wants to
make a difference when it comes to
good guys against the bad guys just one
problem son
[Music]
your partner is one of the bad guys
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
popular 90s tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]